the mood was upbeat in Kiev with
Germany's foreign minister saying these
are historic perhaps decisive days for
Ukraine frank-walter Steinmeier and
ukrainian President Petro poroshenko
both welcomed Putin's backing away from
armed intervention in Ukraine and
Steinmeier expressed support for the
idea that the OSCE could monitor the
ceasefire in eastern Ukraine with
Moscow's participation the topic also
came up during an earlier meeting with
the Ukrainian Prime Minister Arseny
Yatsenyuk but SH ty Meyer said that
eight OSCE monitors captured in eastern
Ukraine would have to be freed first the
surprise breakthrough in the crisis came
in Donetsk on Monday when pro-russian
separatists decided to honor a ceasefire
declared by Ukraine last week with both
sides agreeing to a truce the challenge
now is to find a long-term solution we
hope that during the bilateral ceasefire
we can agree to at least start
consultations on a peaceful resolution
to the conflict outside the meeting
Internet's a small group of protesters
gathered to condemn the Ukrainian
government and its military operations
against the separatists addressing the
concerns of Ukraine's russian-speaking
residents will be a key part of any
peace deal